to do the only thing is if
yeah
no i think roger will probably resign if
he sees e8 queen is not being played
here yet if bishop g4 or bishop d1
there's not much to hope for
there we see fabi
and rajav resides he doesn't wait for
e8 he understands fabi has spotted that
absolutely beautiful game i mean with
ups and downs but it was very clear that
fabi completely outplayed rajavo
and uh he showed his class
also from his side not even that many
down so it was more like but i've done
everything right why am i still not
winning and the composure he showed
to
keep winning the game
i'm very impressed by karana
and this is the thing right that you you
make mistakes you let it go a little bit
but still at the end you you go back and
you grab it back you don't
uh give up you know that okay you made a
mistake but i have to go back and i have
to win it again i have to collect this
game
and but he can do it he can do it and he
did it in in
quite a few times as well so resilient
yeah i think the only move that maybe he
could be kicking himself for was not
going for this rook d8 which looked
much simpler than what he chose but he
never let the wind slip no he was always
winning just he made himself work extra
hard